muy buenos días pues allí donde yo me
encontraba se escuchó una explosión que
hizo temblar las ventanas del lugar en
donde en donde me encontraba yo traté de
abrir y mirar qué era lo que había
sucedido si de pronto había algún sonido
de sirena de algún tipo de ambulancia
pero nada así que los parisinos lo que
hicieron también fue preguntar en las
redes sociales qué es lo que habría
pasado algunos bueno incluso alcanzaron
hasta decir que se trataba de un
atentado terrorista pero no luego el
departamento de bomberos de la capital
explicó en su cuenta de 'twitter' que se
trataba precisamente de un avión que
había atravesado la barrera del sonido'
es decir que iba a más de mil 225
kilómetros por hora y esto era lo que
había pues producido esa fuerte
explosión que se escuchó no sólo en
parís sino en realidad en todos los
suburbios alrededor de la capital un
poco más justamente sobre eso fue a las
1157 de la mañana algo que incluso se
fue transmitido prácticamente en vivo
durante el torneo de roland garros uno
de los partidos allí en ese momento se
interrumpió en el momento de escuchar
esa detonación y bueno se sabe pues que
se trataba de un avión de caza que salió
de la base
sandy en el este de parís y que fue a
ayudar a buscar un avión civil que al
parecer perdió el contacto con la torre
de control y fue el ministerio de
defensa el que le dio el aval a este
avión para que realizara pues este este
vuelo y fuera a esa velocidad
bueno aparentemente fueron susto de
natalia gracias por este reporte desde
la capital francesa